we've always been concerned following
our meeting with seb lat away assured as
it would be open and transparent clearly
it wasn't and the good news today is
that it's not an internal organization
it's the law in the US and the swiss
authorities that are now going to hold
people to account we are hearing from
the US Attorney General as well that
there may have been some corruption
involved in the 2010 world cup as well
it seems that this is this is just the
start of this their investigation and in
terms of the bid process would you like
to see it run again c4 adamant that 20
18 to 20 to 22 we'll go ahead I think
it's difficult to run it again on the
bishes that contracts have been signed
new stereo being built in Russia and in
Qatar so I think it's difficult to go
backwards but the good news is now that
the future of World Cup bids and the
future of football will be open and
transparent now I hope that on Friday
the election doesn't go ahead I believe
that because people are pleaded guilty
that's proof of corruption and that we
need to know have a fresh look at who
should be the right people to run fever
you're putting a very positive spin on
it but let's face it a World Cup bid
isn't cheap England's bid for the 2080
world cup was to the tune of 21 million
pounds all that money spent and the died
were loaded in favor of another country
well I agree with that and you're right
that it'll lots of effort lots of work
went into our bid through the FA through
local authorities and ourselves again of
course where you know upset at that and
if there is a chance for compensation
then we should get that compensation
back financially but I do think it's
more difficult now given that those
contracts a run for 20 18 and 20 22 but
I mean you know as you said it goes back
further than that goes back to 2010 but
not only these issues other issues as
well about what two people have been
doing as a body not being transparent
bring a lawn to themselves and today
that web has been broken and I think
we're going to hear lots more in the
coming days and weeks about further
corruption within FIFA well that's what
the you attorney the US Attorney General
said she said this is the beginning not
the end of the investigation in your
dealings with FIFA in that world cup
2018 bid for England did you see
of corruption or did you have suspicions
we did have suspicions and I attended a
meeting in Brussels a few months ago
with other bodies that bid Australia bid
as well and you know they were concerned
in fact their secret service and let
some certain members of their big team
know that there was corruption around
and the difficulty has been to prove it
the good news now is that the proof is
there people are admitting their guilt
and I think as you say this is a starter
of process not the end of a process yeah
the US Attorney General said Sepp
Blatter is not being charged at this
time we've had Chris Brian later
Labour's shadow Culture Media and Sport
secretary saying that these allegations
happened under Sepp Blatter's watch he
should step aside for the good of FIFA
do you think Sepp Blatter should stand
down even though no allegations have
been made about him specifically he's at
the head of the ship which seems rife
with corruption its reputation is in the
gutter he is a very leading figure
within FIFA I find it an imagined
realtor for him not to have known what
was taking place even if he personally
is not responsible it was under his
watch he is the president and he should
go